I don't think you're going to get any
companies necessarily registering
themselves and that being on Mars in
order to get a tax break give us an
update of what's going on with Mars one
there's a couple of really exciting
things happening we've narrowed down our
astronaut selection to about 100 people
right now we came all the way from
200,000 so it was a lot of work but
we're now down to 100 and still quite a
few from the US but from 35 different
countries and the most exciting thing
that I'm spending a lot of time on is
and investment rounds that we are
hopefully closing soon with a small
consortium of investors for an amount of
money that can really take Mars one a
few steps into the direction of actually
performing our first unmanned mission in
2020 what's the estimate for the cost of
putting these four astronauts on Mars
right now add the total cost of having
the first four humans including all the
preparatory missions that we do before
the humans go it's about six billion
u.s. dollars now there has been some
criticism saying that that figure is too
low what's your response a lot of people
that's that look at our cost figure
think oh that's a lot lower than what
NASA has been saying and as naming
number starting somewhere in the in the
60 60 billion so that's a lot higher
than our six billion but what these
people often forget is that a return
mission is at least an order of
magnitude more complex and therefore
more expensive than a permanent
settlement mission a return mission
means developing bigger rockets on earth
developing in a whole new way of landing
systems on Mars developing the
capability of launching something from
Mars it's even difficult to launch
things from Earth five to ten percent of
all satellite launches end up in a
satellite that's not in the right orbit
so how can we even imagine doing that
from Mars and that's what makes our
mission affordable it's also what makes
it possible from a risk perspective from
a financial perspective and from a
technology perspective I'm glad you
mentioned the the financial perspective
because that is linked to what has
turned into a delay in the launch dates
and wonder if you can explain that yeah
we originally want to wanted to lend our
first crew in 20-25 because of the
investment round that I just
ancient clothing that has been taking
longer than we were hoping I think it
usually does but the delay in closing
that investment round has caused us to
have to delay our first unmanned mission
from 20 18 to 20 20 and therefore all
our other missions by two years leading
to the human landing in 20 27 operating
on Mars and going to Mars potentially a
reality television spectacular can you
give us an update on the details of
production companies that you might or
might not work with in order to showcase
this we have a production company under
contract to to make our series for
currently negotiation with multiple
broadcasters did this would be the
documentary series around the astronaut
selection of finding for people that can
actually do one of the most difficult
jobs that you can imagine leaving
everything and everyone behind for the
rest of their lives so it will be a
documentary series and I don't really
like the term reality TV because it's it
takes us to a big brother or or Jersey
Shore I prefer comparing our Marsh
mission to the Olympic Games that we're
going to find the best people of the
planet we're going to do something that
almost nobody else can do and we're
going to share that story with the world
in a beautiful way just like the
Olympics Games show stories in a very
beautiful way